what we have here is a really
interesting
visual that shows world population
growth
from 1750 all the way to 2100 and
obviously this isn't
2100 yet so it's doing some projecting
for roughly the next 80 years
and it also shows the absolute world
population over that time period
so just to make sure we're understanding
this graphic our horizontal axis here we
can see
the years going by you can view that as
our time axis
starting with 1750 right over here going
all the way to 2100
now we are here in when i'm making this
video is 2021
but this graphic was made in 2015. so
everything beyond
2015 is considered to be a projection
now on this left-hand vertical axis this
is
really the rate of world population
growth the growth rate that it has here
and i could write that down just to make
it
more clear this is the growth rate
axis and we have a right vertical axis
here because we're really showing two
different things we're showing the
annual growth rate of world population
in red
and then we're showing the absolute
world population in this blue curve
right over here
and so we could view this axis as
world population
now there's a bunch of really
interesting things here one you might
just wonder what was the world
population around
1750 and if you look at this and these
are obviously
estimates because you did not have a
global census back in 1750
it was around 700 or 800 million people
now what's interesting is that's not a
lot larger
than the number of people that we had at
say the time of jesus which is also the
time of the roman empire and
han china where it's estimated that
around that time period around 2000
years ago
the world population was around 300
million people
but then we see something interesting
happening over the next
several centuries from 1750 it seems to
start growing
pretty dramatically and we could see why
that is we can see the
the growth rate of population for a
while if we look at this red curve
the growth rate of world population
was around 0.6 percent but it looks like
in the early 20th century
right around here the rate of
growth of world population starts to
really
increase where at least based on this it
looks like
around the 1970s
world population the growth rate peaked
out at 2.1 percent
now the question might be why was this
happening why did the rate of growth
increase so much
well the main argument is as we became a
more
industrial society health care would
have improved so
child mortality would have gone down
people would have died of
fewer diseases at the same time we would
have gotten more efficient
with agriculture we would have had
modern farming methods so
more people so food would get cheaper it
would be more abundant more people would
have access to nutrition
and all of those would drive the growth
rate
up now an interesting question that
folks have been thinking about for
many hundreds of years is there a limit
to how much human population
the earth can sustain and so they've
introduced this idea known as
carrying capacity why do we use the
letter k for capacity when capacity
starts with a c
because a version of that word in german
starts with a k
and there's always been this notion that
for a given species there's got to be
some
maximum capacity that an ecosystem can
con
can sustain and there's folks like
thomas malthus who's theorized that
there must be some
limit to how many people there could be
on the planet just based on how much
land there is how much nutrition
or how much resources there are but the
carrying capacity for
humanity is really an open question
because
our technology is constantly on the move
we constantly are getting better
at using using our resources more
efficiently going into new ecosystems
now it's a huge debate how sustainable
is that
and as we become more efficient are we
also trashing certain parts of our
ecosystem
but the carrying capacity of humans we
really don't know how many people the
planet earth
could sustain but we could see that the
rate of population growth starts to
decline
after 1970. and the main argument for
this and we've seen this and we covered
this in other videos when we study
countries that are still developing and
countries that would be considered
industrial or even post-industrial
is that as countries develop and become
wealthier
you might have more women entering into
the workforce you might
have more family planning women have
more control over their destiny get
education longer
and people just have fewer children and
so
as people have fewer children you could
see that the world
that especially we see this in
industrial and post-industrial countries
the growth rate starts to come down and
so the aggregate growth rate is coming
down arguably because more and more
countries are becoming wealthier have
better health care
better rights for women and we even see
today that when you look at
countries that are developing their
growth rate is around 1.2 percent while
more economically developed nations
are around 0.2 so there's definitely
that correlation between the two
and of course this growth rate that you
see in red is going to affect the
absolute population
and so it's no coincidence that at the
same time that the growth rate started
to go
up like that we see that the population
in absolute terms starts to accelerate
and just over
let's say the last hundred years we've
gone from
1.65 billion or i guess if we go back
100 years to 1920. it looks like we're
approaching
2 billion folks and now we're sitting at
roughly seven and a half billion folks
so the world population roughly doubled
over the
let's say 2000 years prior to this chart
but then over this chart over just the
last 270 years
our world population has grown pretty
much
by a factor of 10. now we don't know how
sustainable that would be if our growth
rate were to continue
but it does look like that growth rate
is monitoring moderating and at least
the projections in this chart
have a starting to approach 11 billion
maybe over time 12 billion
and maybe stabilize someplace around
there but it's an interesting thing
to think about